[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host NBC football night America and
uh one of the most knowledgeable
football people we have doing this
joining us on the program princy and I
had a debate I don't want to say it was
a heated debate but we had a debate
about the philanthropic Aaron Rodgers
giving back to the Jets here fritzy
thinks that somehow somewhere down the
road Rogers will get that money back I
thought it's still a nice gesture to
give the Jets 35 million dollars back
help us understand what Rogers is doing
and is it honorable
princi's instincts are right I've Got a
Theory on this and since I've been
labeled one of the top five conspiracy
theorists in the NFL I have to work hard
to continue to hold that status here's
what I think is going to happen and this
all comes from and I'll give you the
chain of events Ben Fisher of sports
Business Journal reported on Tuesday
afternoon evening that the NFL last week
passed a rule preventing owners from
giving Equity to players or other
employees in the aftermath of that
report surfacing I talked to some people
and I learned
that is Aaron Rodgers was reconfiguring
his contract with the Jets Dan he was
trying to get
equity in the franchise my theory is
this 33.7 million dollar gift to Woody
Johnson which is exactly what it is
because look Dan they could have found a
way to move money around and load up the
team this year and next year and they
could have dealt with the salary cap
issues after Rogers was long gone this
gift I predict five six seven years down
the road will result in Aaron Rodgers
being sold a small percentage of the New
York Jets book it now I predict it will
happen later
well I won't be doing this
I saw that yeah I'll be retired by then
so fritzy and I I guess will have an
argument over the phone maybe but he
could have kept his deal though Mike
right
oh he could have he could have and look
Dan I'd been plugged into this for
months from the point that Rogers
unexpectedly took a 58 million dollar
option bonus that was due this year
moved it to next year to give the
Packers the team that he supposedly
hates at least the front office some cap
relief on his way out the door and the
Jets and Rogers had to figure out how
they're going to reallocate that money I
had heard that he was possibly going to
take less money from the Jets than he
was supposed to make this year and next
year from the Packers and I think the
strategy here is and we have to assume
Aaron Rodgers is smart so he's strategic
you ingratiate yourself to the team to
the locker room to the front office to
the fan base to the media and the
thinking is you appear to be unselfish
you appear to be a guy who's helping the
team and you make it all back one way or
the other sponsorship deals appreciation
of the percentage you buy down the road
whatever it is you're going to make that
33.7 million dollars back at some point
down the road and I think that's part of
his calculation he'll get that back and
then some and he rides into New York and
he stays the hero and everyone's going
to go easy on him and everyone's going
to praise him and no one's ever going to
ask him a tough question because he's
such a great guy who took 33.7 million
less
any other quarterbacks doing this
well I mean Patrick Mahomes is in a
roundabout way Patrick Mahomes is
content to be grossly underpaid and
Chiefs fans just love it when I point
that out but Mahomes three years ago was
the highest paid quarterback at 45
million now you've got Justin Herbert at
52.5 it's just a matter of time before
Joe burrow goes higher than Herbert
Mahomes meanwhile seems to be content to
be underpaid and Tom Brady's the guy
that got all this started being
underpaid to help with the construction
of the team and this is where the system
is rigged against the great quarterbacks
because they make the game go they are
worth more to the league than they are
to their individual teams how do they
pick the Prime Time games every year by
where the quarterbacks are going to be
so if we had a chance to do it all over
again I think you should have a league
Wide Fund that pays the great
quarterbacks because they mean more to
the shield than they do to their teams
and the salary cap gets used as leverage
to get them to take less in the hopes of
winning yeah we've proposed that for a
while now that just have a separate
salary cap for your quarterbacks or can
we do something with the running backs
that we we start them out with a
three-year deal or we let them leave
College after their sophomore year
is there any solution that would help
everybody and the owners don't go you
know we're still not paying
well don't tell Jim ersei he's already
making it clear that nothing will be
done which isn't going to help the cause
he would have been better off saying
nothing because these guys are mad and
if you have an owner saying things like
he said last night on Twitter they're
only going to get more upset this is an
organic realization by the running backs
that the system screws them the the
weirdest part about this Dan has it been
the case for 15 years that running backs
have been taken advantage of when did it
start Mike when well do you remember
I I asked someone last week what's the
root cause of this issue somebody who's
been involved in the league at a high
level for a long time with one of the
teams and I was told blame analytics and
Mike Shanahan go all the way back to
1999. Terrell Davis tears his ACL olanda
scary comes in and has 1100 plus rushing
yards in 1999. 2000 I don't know what
happened to Orlando's Gary but Mike
Anderson has 1400 rushing yards in that
system it's the system that makes it go
so you can you can throw a rock and find
a running back who can come in and make
it happen every major college every year
has a running back that could play
running back at the NFL level the supply
outweighs the demand you throw on top of
that this analytics obsession with
Surplus value where's the Surplus value
not at the running back position it's a
quarterback receiver pass rusher and
Corner that's it the other positions are
viewed as interchangeable so it's hard
for the great players to get paid and
for running backs by the time you're 27
28 years old you've got a lot of mileage
you're expecting a lot of money there's
younger and cheaper guys out there
that's how it all happened what's
amazing is finally the running backs are
standing up and saying this is
unacceptable I just don't know what they
can do about it they can't do anything
and and we were just talking about this
that people go well you bargained for
this collective bargaining agreement you
can't slip in language that says and by
the way
um can we have running backs be paid
commensurate to wide receivers it
doesn't happen the owners aren't going
to let you you could try to put that in
there but that's not gonna they took
years trying to get
marijuana testing taken out of the NFL I
don't think you're going to slip in a
clause that said hey running backs are
grossly underpaid we get it but you know
quarterbacks are not grossly underpaid
or wide receivers aren't defensive
tackles aren't tackles left tackles
aren't it's just middle linebackers and
running backs are underpaid
Dan here's the problem the union is
hopelessly conflicted here because it
represents all shapes and sizes of
players so you rob Peter to pay Paul if
you're going to help the running backs
if you're going to get the league to do
something to improve running back pay
the league is going to say what's in it
for us what are you giving us in return
you may hurt some other position as you
try to maintain that balance between
labor and management running backs
arguably should have their own Union
there was an effort in Chicago four
years ago to create a running back
bargaining unit it went nowhere that's
one way to do this Dan the other thing
you do and and I don't know that this
will ever work but this is the best
thing that I've managed to come up with
if all the running backs would get
together now and if they would get all
running backs currently in the league
and all agents to commit that next
year's crop running backs will go along
with this if they say next year for the
off season program you're not going to
have a single running back present on
any team and if they can if they can
sell that as something they can pull off
and I don't think they can pull it off
but if they could pull that off that
would be a way to get the League's
attention and maybe get them to figure
out something and the best this is a
Chris Simms solution you may have
mentioned it on your show earlier this
week the idea of having a league Wide
Fund of money that pays running backs
for performance because they do their
best work when they're under peanuts
deals in comparison to what veteran
players make pay them then when they
have 1500 rushing yards and 15 rushing
touchdowns
Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host
um
is the NFL done with Daniel Snyder
well I I think there's one open issue as
far as the NFL is related and this
dawned on me last night
the finding for Mary Jo White's report
that the commanders essentially moved
money around moved Revenue around from
NFL events to non-nfl events at FedEx
Field concerts college football games in
order to avoid sharing money with the
teams that money also would have gone
into the pot that determines the salary
cap so the NFL players Association may
have something to say about this and
when I read that report last week Dan it
was clear to me that Mary Jo White was
providing a blueprint for a prosecution
under Virginia Maryland or federal law
each one potentially would have some
degree of jurisdiction I don't know
what's going to happen if there's going
to be a prosecution if the statutes of
limitations haven't expired but she
basically found fraudulent conduct she
never used the word fraud but she found
fraud and if you do any research of the
laws out there and it's all available to
anyone who's curious there are laws in
every state many laws against fraud and
people get prosecuted for fraudulent
schemes all the time so the NFL may be
done with him but the NFL PA may have
something to say and there may be some
aggressive prosecutors out there taking
a look at Mary Jo White's report Dalvin
cook visiting the Jets your thoughts
well I got some extra money thank you
Rogers yeah right yeah and his cap
number if he hadn't redone his deal
before he left the Packers his cap
number would have been 15 million or so
when the Jets acquired him his cap
number now is about 8 million so there's
7 million right there they didn't expect
to have and Breese Hall who was off to a
great start last year as a rookie he
tore his ACL they're not 100 certain
he's going to be ready to go week one or
he's going to be the guy he was last
year and Dalvin Cook's available and
they're all in and they could pull that
off and and really at the end of the day
this is 33 yeah you know how good you
feel when you find a 20 Bill and a pair
of pants you haven't worn in three
months Woody Johnson found 33.7 million
dollars in a pair of pants today he's
got plenty of money to go get Dalvin
cook yeah because Aaron Rodgers is very
generous that's right yeah is that a
charitable deduction like is that a
write-off for Aaron Rodgers yeah it's
not a write-off because it was never in
he just gave it up but yeah he should
have found some other way to manage his
tax bracket but again it'll all work out
when he owns 1.327 of the New York Jets
seven years from now do you hate Aaron
Rodgers no I don't Harry I
I have a ton of respect for Aaron
Rodgers I like the fact that there's
kind of a healthy
disagreement from afar I think he and I
he may disagree with me on this I think
he and I have a lot more in common than
anyone ever realizes and I don't think
he would ever agree with that not even
in one respect okay
uh if you had to bet on coaches getting
fired mid-season we had three last year
who mid-season well depending upon what
happens with the Chargers it wouldn't
stun me this new deal for Justin Herbert
just puts more pressure on Brandon
Staley and what did we last see from
Brandon Staley a playoff appearance
and a historic flame out against the
Jaguars where they blew a 28-point lead
so I think he's got a ton of pressure on
him going into the season it look
there's always going to be a team that
that stumbles out of the gates what does
the owner do when you're oh and four one
in five two and seven and you had all
those expectations not all that long ago
to be a competitive team so it all comes
down to how the owner is wired and what
the owner decides to do in that stress
and strain of the moment but I'd be very
nervous this year if I'm Brandon Staley
because all that money to Justin Harbert
if it doesn't work this year it's not
like you're getting rid of Herbert
they're getting rid of me and there's
coaches already circling at charge's job
they were doing it last year Dan they
when they you know the coaches who are
eyeballing NFL jobs they want to work
with the franchise quarterback they want
to work with Justin Herbert well Sean
Payton
I mean I don't know this but between
Broncos and Chargers if both jobs are
open you're taking a Chargers job if
you're Sean Payton yeah
um
oh I I said this earlier what what is a
uh considered a great season for the
Jets like that it or maybe what what
would be a bad season for the Jets
you're not making the playoffs okay
let's say they make the playoffs
I said if you do one and done then you
didn't have a great year
I would agree with that especially
because that's been the Aaron Rodgers
flaw failure to deliver in the
postseason great in the regular season
the playoffs come around and this is one
of Sims complaints about Aaron Rodgers
not mine so Aaron don't blame me for
this one Sims believes that when the
season is riding on that one game in
January Rogers is too careful Rogers
doesn't let it rip Rogers is too
concerned about throwing an interception
that he doesn't just go out and play the
way that he did from week one through
week 18. and there's too many times
they've been the one seed they've lost
at home I mean it's it goes all the way
back to 2011. the year after they won
the Super Bowl they were the one seed
and the Giants went into Lambeau Field
and beat them we saw them lose to the
49ers at Lambeau Field they lost to the
Buccaneers the year before that both
years Aaron Rodgers was the league MVP
so he's got to deliver when it's one and
done pressure but first they got to get
there Dan and I apologize if I'm
repeating myself of something I said on
your show before look at the schedules
of the teams in the AFC East they play
each other twice they play every team
from the AFC West they play every team
from the NFC East if you don't win that
division yeah you may not get in because
you're going to be compared then to the
second and third place teams from the
other divisions that have easier
schedules it's going to be very hard for
the second place team and the AFC East
to get in so if the Jets don't win the
division they may not get in I know I
brought that up after you had mentioned
that because sometimes we just look at a
team and look at the talent and we go oh
you can pencil in 11 wins and then I
always say look at this schedule and see
if you can pencil in 11 or 12 wins there
and when you start to look at who you
have to play
there's no gimmies used to be with the
Patriots the rest of the division was a
gimme and you'd be like all right let me
lock in six wins here well that's not
the case anymore so I I think there's
11 wins would be a good I think a good
start for the Jets that and that you
look at that schedule where are 11 wins
and you could argue their week one game
at home against the bills is the most
important game of the year because if
they lose that one of the bills then
they have to go play in Buffalo later in
the year you get swept by the bills you
ain't winning that division you got to
make up three games the rest of the year
to catch and pass the bills so they need
to hold serve in those Legacy white
uniforms that you can buy wherever your
equipment is sold please go buy buy buy
more because yeah well I mean yeah Woody
Johnson made 33.7 million yesterday but
he truly like to make a lot more but
that week one game critical and we're
going to know a lot about the Jets by
the time it's week four when the Chiefs
come to town
who do you think dislikes Aaron Rodgers
morph fritzy or Mike Florio Paulie uh
clearly fritzy Mike's using it as a tool
and it's working well for him okay thank
you but Mike then you're saying Mike
just called Aaron Rodgers a tool no
Rogers
that's what I took from that uh Seton
who do you think dislikes Aaron Rodgers
more uh I'm gonna go Mike actually okay
I'm gonna go Mike okay yeah
um Marvin
I'ma go fritzy okay so we're split here
uh and what's your vote I'm gonna go
fritzy okay I think you're skip
baylessing uh Aaron Rodgers the way skip
does LeBron James
you know
it's so much respect
Association
right now I apologize I mean there's no
reason to get nasty I apologize I
apologize
I apologize that's all right Mike thanks
for joining us good talking to you
that's Mike Florida pro football time
the look on Mike's face when I said your
skip baylessing Aaron Rodgers the way
skip does LeBron James and his face sort
of was like what